chipper and I used to live next to each
other 40 minutes north of Turner Field
we got to go to Turner Field because
there's a luncheon that we got to go and
talk we got alerts that were like hey
it's about the snow I had to try and get
home and it wasn't like snowing downpour
it was ice so it took nine hours for me
to get off of the exit of where I lived
nine hours there was peeing in bottles
you know what are you gonna do finally I
got to a shopping center my phone was
dying I had one percent left chipper
texted me and says where are you and I
said I don't know the exact location but
I took a picture sent it and then boom
phone died it's 45 minutes later there's
a guy coming in camo on an ATV and it's
chipper and full camo and he's like
let's go we're going home leather jacket
and I had Louboutin shoes on it's like
20 degrees and we're on an ATV he's
going like as fast as this ATV he can go
I am like like holding on to him for
dear life Atlanta wasn't prepared for
the snow and then they made a bobble
head out of